[Musique]
ils ont particulièrement besoin des
donneurs en ce moment parce qu'à cause
du coc vide les entreprises les gens
sont allés télétravail donc les grosses
entreprises qui avaient l'habitude de
faire des collectes ou les lycées ou les
universités libère les créneaux on est
sur un sur un bassin d'entreprises et
d'habitation parce qu'entre les bons ya
2200 du temps je crois a tous eu
aujourd'hui il ya surtout un bassin
d'entreprises va c'est assez important
avec notre aérodrome qui est à distance
à pied de la salle du plessis c'est un
petit village
donc là on va pouvoir cibler aussi les
entreprises qui n'ont pas nécessairement
les moyens ou l'envié ou l'idée le temps
d'organiser leur propre collecte
il ya beaucoup de jeunes sur la commune
donc j'aimerais bien sensibiliser
particulièrement ce public parce que je
pense qu'une fois qu'on a donné qu'on a
vaincu la peur de la piqûre ou qu'on a
vaincu ses essais et ses ses
appréhensions je pense qu'après ça
devient quelque chose de naturel